[Music]
Dutch artist Pete Mondrian's abstract
rectangular paintings inspired
mathematicians to create a two-fold
challenge
first we must completely cover a square
canvas with non overlapping rectangles
all must be unique so if we use a 1 by 4
we can't use a 4 by 1 in another spot
but a 2 by 2 rectangle would be fine
let's try that say we have a canvas
measuring 4 by 4 we can't chop it
directly in half since that would give
us identical rectangles of 2 by 4 but
the next closest option 3 by 4 and 1 by
4 works that was easy but we're not done
yet
now take the area of the largest
rectangle and subtract the area of the
smallest the result is our score and the
goal is to get as low a score as
possible here the largest area is 12 and
the smallest is 4 giving us a score of 8
since we didn't try to go for a low
score that time we can probably do
better
let's keep our 1 by 4 while breaking the
3 by 4 into a 3 by 3 and a 3 by 1 now
our score is 9 minus 3 or 6 still not
optimal but better with such a small
canvas there are only a few options but
let's see what happens when the canvas
gets bigger try out an 8 by 8 what's the
lowest score you can get
to get our bearings we can start as
before dividing the canvas roughly into
that gives us a five by eight rectangle
with area forty and a three by eight
with area 24 for a score of 16 that's
pretty bad
dividing that 5 by 8 into a 5 by 5 and a
5 by 3 leaves us with a score of 10
better but still not great we could just
keep dividing the biggest rectangle but
that would leave us with increasingly
tiny rectangles which would increase the
range between the largest and smallest
what we really want is for all our
rectangles to fall within a small range
of area values and since the total area
of the canvas is 64 the areas need to
add up to that let's make a list of
possible rectangles and areas to improve
on our previous score we can try to pick
a range of values spanning nine or less
and adding up to 64 you'll notice that
some values are left out because
rectangles like 1 by 13 or 2 by 9 won't
fit on the canvas you might also realize
that if you use one of the rectangles
with an odd area like 5 9 or 15 you need
to use another odd value rectangle to
get an even some with all that in mind
let's see what works
starting with area 20 or more puts us
over the limit too quickly but we can
get to 64 using rectangles in the 14 to
18 range leaving out 15 unfortunately
there's no way to make them fit using
the 2 by 7 leaves a gap that can only be
filled by a rectangle with a width of 1
going lower the next range that works is
8 to 14 leaving out the 3x3 square this
time the pieces fit that's a score of 6
can we do even better no we can get the
same score by throwing out the 2 by 7
and 1 by 8 and replacing them with a 3
by 3 1 by 7 & 1 by 6 but if we go any
lower down the list the numbers become
so small that we'd need a wider range of
sizes to cover the canvass which would
increase the score there's no trick or
formula here just a bit of intuition
it's more art than science and for
larger grids expert mathematicians
aren't sure whether they've found the
lowest possible scores so how would you
divide a 4 by 4 10 by 10 or 32 by 32
canvas give it a try and post your
results in the comments if you enjoyed
this riddle and want more like it head
on over to brilliant org sign up for
free and check out the joy of problem
solving in crazy cut polyomino puzzles
you can explore the geometry of cutting
reconnecting and tiling using this link
will help support ted-ed and get you 20%
off brilliance annual premium
subscription fee